[Music]
hello everybody
so yeah the problem we are going to tell
you a little bit about is how to detect
catchy phrases in Polish internet and
catchy topics potentially also in Polish
Internet and we also talked a little bit
about how to solve this problem that
data is really not there how to get it
and at the end if you have some
questions we're happy to to talk a
little bit about it ok cool so why even
bother
so Feeny is startup so we like 9 months
old 10 months old and we have a
marketing department and the marketing
department has to do a lot of stuff but
one of it is actually write content for
our website so that people come in and
read and get traffic so so they they
wanted to know what they can write about
their marketing you should know right
and and what people what makes people
click if anything so so they came to me
and said I dude can you help you're
supposed to be like data [ __ ] stuff you
know wizards
you know spells and we said ok we can
try and and actually we we did it it's
not complete success but it actually
helps then we've work the problem we
needed to solve is that we already we
don't really know what makes people
click because we didn't hack yet Gazeta
pal super Express spell and other things
but we do have social networks and
people are super you know extrovert
there and they click like love and stuff
so you can use this as a surrogate for
for for some reaction-time so this is a
story about how how we made our
marketing guys life a little bit better
so as with anything in data science we
try to follow a process having worked in
consulting for like over 10 years I know
and and starting some type
the science projects for financial
services I know that this is actually
not very obvious for most of the
business guys because usually they
here's some data figure out [ __ ] right
data is new so solve me problems so we
actually first defined a problem
statement improve life of our marketing
guys so they have inspirations to write
topics and tests the text and how to
improve existing text their headlines if
possible in a measurable way so that
people click more that was the problem
statement it is actually done in a
measurable way then we said ok we never
done that before so maybe we'll select
some tools turns out my team knows some
Python so we figured out that we might
use some Python we didn't want to write
scrapers for all the internet because
that's [ __ ] boring so so we decided
we use something called 71 because
marketing check so there's someone
writes about Feeney maybe it's good
maybe it's bad but it's good to know so
it takes some work out of us then we did
some research Miha will tell about about
some packages we used so so which which
packages we used then we needed to get
some data so we you send you on API
turns out they have API so we we used it
we gathered we got the data set that
makes modeling a little bit easier and
then obviously the coolship data
engineering feature engineering modeling
hyperparameters tuning so we talked a
little bit about that turns out it's not
very obvious in in the text space and
actually something that no no data
scientist wants as they say every model
is great until it's actually application
so we actually made application of the
model and and deployed it to production
so this this broke some things but now
it works all right me how so ok so
that's what what was our problem
and so for that we need to gather some
data to solve the problem one one of the
sources of our data was Facebook Graph
up API
oh sorry now you can hear me okay so one
source of data was Facebook Graph API
else - don't download posts from
selected fanpage
and a lot of data about this post like
number of shares number of likes okay
number of likes and URL - short content
and our marketing team gave us a list of
this house
which we used to
okay so our marketing team gave us a
list of most important polish financial
portals and and we are gathering data
from this Facebook Graph Appy which is
hosted on Azure there is daily scheduled
web job and another data source was sent
in one API it also download articles
from selected list of hosts and a lot of
other stuff like author of the article
or URL to that article and use the data
to find find out where the heart
characteristics of the most popular
articles right on the facebook so in the
previous year we gathered thirty three
hundred thousand article text from sent
one API from this only from this list of
holes to defined by our marketing
marketing team
we also download at sixty sixty thousand
Facebook posts from Facebook Graph API
and we were able to join these two
datasets by URL to to this article which
is which we use to compute various
statistics to train topic model and to
to to describe these topics
the datasets 30,000 articles so first
problem is those headline mother
so there's headline making thing so
first we need to create like a measure
of what is what is virality what we
named it virality in a in a in a way
obviously there is no agreed way but we
talk with our marketing guys and decided
that there is a experts weighted
combination of likes shares comments
that we will use as a score of how
attractive this text was and we tagged
and labeled every article in our
database that we got me how described in
the previous previous step obviously
this is expert based however clearly we
took into consideration that effort it
is to make a like to make a comment and
to make a shirt and how much it is worth
within marketing marketing teams after
we we had that we were able to do a some
actual modeling and now why did we so so
you know there is like things like
sarios Volsky
considering the big candidate for
election in european union but you can
really predict it and it doesn't make
sense to write it after it's it's
written so we needed to make some
measures invent some measures that will
allow us to determine if you're
something that's constant I mean it's
not a one-time thing
and something that's that's coming up
one in in a while or is one-time event
and for that we use entropy mija will
will explain after under the next slide
so turns out something something is in
the headline the headline is actual
predictor so check that out right change
a roof kaviraja
so terrorists at
cool people like to read about it people
react about it
and this actually sad however when we
talk about social issues like
photovoltaics free money actually
generates a lot of buzz in general
general all the old legislation effort
in the current government generate quite
a lot of buzz unless they're super quiet
like this this this legislation that
nobody knows about it sorry for ski
right one-hit-wonder you can't really
predict that terrorist attacks you can
really predict that and it's hard to
react and especially doesn't make much
sense in the financial services context
right so okay more constant reworks
phrases like look out for some tips
about security maybe something and also
man is quite a viral topic and constant
over time and also think things which
are happening on Facebook are quite
quite viral okay we also checked what
are good opening phrases for headlines
of articles and it turns out that good
opening phrase is someone is dead and
it's good opening phrases are about
Polish companies and about arguments for
example president he's our favorite and
don't tell them that size doesn't matter
sighs actually matters in terms of
headlines actually no actually size
matters and turns out you can't be too
long this time
you have to be rather on the short side
turns out is around twenty five thirty
letters total is the best clickable
things and also don't make it too
complicated people don't like long
headlines they're boring like it means
it's probably boring in hard stuff so so
clearly when we presented that our
marketing is like oh [ __ ] okay so now
they write shorter shorter topics way
way shorter and actually helped yeah
where's the thingy right but we also did
some nice about the sequences right yes
we check what what influence of how type
of sentence influences virality
so the best phrases are exclamations and
least least favorite ones are questions
in the difference and the difference
between these two are is exclamations
are two times better than questions so
it's quite the quite big difference yeah
okay so all the analysis we did up to
this point only takes into account
headlines and lots of articles if we
want to get deeper get better insights
we have to analyze content of the
article tech main text but for that we
need a tool which I'll just to get from
any page we want an article we want so
we talked about that in yeah it's so
because we had 71 you ask why would we
do that somebody already extracted the
text from for us well when you remember
that who had sixty thousand articles on
Facebook and only thirty thousand
mattress so there's like another set
the same size that we could extract if
we had automated way to extract text
from a website and clearly writing the
bots to extract text is in the case
because it will take like hundreds and
thousands of hours so so that's not cool
enough clearly the problem is very easy
visually right when you see humans are
designed to to read that text and if the
text is unreadable the site will die
because it will have no viewers so for
humans it's super easy but for the
computer is not that easy making the
automated text extractor is actually a
hot topic because you essentially need
to buy a building a Google but there are
a lot of papers that solve this I mean
offer hints to solve it visually so
render a page measure the dimensions of
the text fields then create some
extractor and extract the text using
something like selenium bot or other
similar techniques but this is super
expensive if you have 30,000 articles
you would have to build an engine that
renders them extracts it visually train
a neural network this takes a lot of
computational effort and a lot of a lot
of money actually so for this small task
this is not a viable way so we decided
to use maybe a little less accurate way
but actually parse the text and see
whether or not we can build a general
machine that an extract article out of
raw HTML right HTML is good enough it it
is an instruction to our browser to
render it so maybe there is a model that
can actually read it and extract the
text out of it so Amy how did we do
something so I will describe our
approach for that problem so first we
extract all the text from web page and
web page we want and then we have to
decide for each text whether it is
article or not and for that we need a
classifier
but the train a classifier one of the
data sets so we have this data set from
senti one where we have a pair of each
HTML code and text from that web page so
we made a simpler go it which labels
text in text in web page whether it
belongs to the article or or not and
from that we have we have a data set
which with without labels so let's skip
this slide first about some feature
engineering so you've got all the a lot
of this text and for each text we have
to have to describe in some numeric way
so so we can then train on classifier on
it so we competed for each text a lot of
features like death of the text in HTML
3 number of words in of the text the
text density saw the no ratio of the
number of characters to all the
characters in then in that element and
we repeated the computations of these
features for parents grandparents and we
concatenated all these features into one
long vector for for one text okay so we
trained a classifier on this data set we
trained friend of ours and extra boost
and we use a parameter to using group
cross-validation where group was defined
by host so group cross-validation
cross-validation where your faults are
defined by values of some grouping
variable okay in our classical skulls
because we didn't want to offer over fit
too much two layers of specific web
portals which we were
which were in our dataset yes and we
trained to classifiers we made an
example of them by simply arranging
their predictions so if you want to use
our algorithm new web page we have to
first extract all the text from that
HTML code then for each text we compute
the features then for each text we
classify whether it belongs to the
article content or not and and text
labeled us by our classifier as article
are merged to one-to-one text which we
return as an article text okay so we
train some classifiers so we can we can
tell what are the important features in
our dataset to decide whether it is
article or not some some of them were
definite about three lines of parent
number of scene blinks or number of
characters in that tag so a little bit
about the results how to measure that
actually it's a classifiers but the
accuracy or I you see is actually
useless because I don't care about one
one line or one tag classification there
are other right precision recall and we
found one more jacquard index and that's
the actually results precision and
recall has actually pretty good
interpretation so we extract 90% of the
text that actually is there in total so
90% of the articles is classified
correctly and the other thing is that of
all all think we extract 90% is
something that we it's worth something
right it's correct
so and this is how much did we spend
for like a week maybe building this
model even less and we see potential to
maybe getting this thing to 95 and with
95% is actually pretty good because 95%
in an automated way and this is taking
consideration
it's trained results on the horse that
the algorithm never seen before
considering it's obviously polish
Internet but we can usually I think it's
trap elated that because people write
content in a similar way all languages
using Latin alphabet should be similar
obviously Muslim when it's written
left-right might be different probably
Chinese would be a little bit different
but this should work so so we were
pretty happy with that because 90% of
the extraction should be there and
because they approach we used in the
topic distinction 90% was considered for
us good enough and usually because we
want to predict topic of article topic
doesn't usually care about 10% of
article content that topic is something
that's general about articles or 90% of
correctness should be enough all right
so so about the topic we wanted to know
what topics are hot because then I go to
marketing or that should they go to our
dashboard and say they know what they
write about they don't you know
fantasize too much or they don't they
don't actually come to us and tell us
for inspiration
so we needed some approach to topic
modeling because having 60000 articles
it's quite a lot to label so we decided
to automate that stuff okay but first we
had to do some text pre-processing so
first we done some standard stuff like
limit ization tokenization stop words
removal inter functional removal and
lower casing and then we don't
motivation so basically we took each
word and based on some dictionary of all
the forms of all the words in Polish
language we transformed them to their
base forms and that was
input to light and different allocation
so it is a proper basic graphical model
which uses a lot of latent variables it
uses bag-of-words text representation so
it discussed discards order of words in
our data set it's a track extracts given
number of topics Erik terrific for that
set of text and each topic is a
probability distribution of awards so we
can tell how likely each word is to
occur in the topic it also assigns topic
probabilities for each text so we can
decide whether the text has specific
topic and we used against him package
for that model it to spread spread
computations for mood multiple cores and
it's very fast okay so the outputs of LD
a is our topics and topic distributions
for each document so topics are probably
distributions of rewards so we can
describe topics using this most the most
probable words in that topic so for
example if we had these words right here
we can tell that first first topic is
about French presidential elections and
the second one is about pensions and
retirement or something okay so we've
got also this topic distributions for
each article so these are telling us how
how much of the topic is an is in the
article so these give us weights by
which we can yes or we can compute some
expiratory statistics about which with
Walker
yeah cool so you know we like micro
where politics guys so so we did some
reactions what people are doing turns
out that actually reactions are that
ones the ones we expect likes dominate
likes are like eighty percent of all the
reactions in Facebook because like is
the default action the second action is
the love action and the third one is the
haha action check out you see the more
effort it makes the movie with a mouse
the harder it is to click it if they
moved this sad face
to the first one I guarantee you it
would be the second best so this is
actually worthless information but we
did some analysis of what this what this
Lda found on over the 60 thousand
articles and turns out we had sheesh
colo a lot of coverage guys we had
obviously a lot of political context
like you know that legislation
legislation topics are super hot so this
abortion thing low super hot but we also
found like financial results like a lot
of articles you know banker ppl or
Tefilin or money ppl publishes results
and we classified those some random
[ __ ] like he changed name to iphone
7 like there is like a classified and
classification had random [ __ ] and it's
just one of random [ __ ] like PR texts we
have a lot of PR text where the brand
name occurs because when you think about
it the brand name occurs in PR texts
because PR writes it and every text has
a lot of it so it's quite easy to find
so what is viral PR she is not viral at
all like result financial results not
viral
like generally thinks about like
politics non polish politics not viral
but like Cisco Damon everything about
politics right now polarizes people and
it's like a statistical example that
actually makes sense to write about
banking legislation and how it will
affect you like a regular dude regular
Joe regular n and that's a great insight
we pass to the marketing team yeah so so
how the topic over time looks this is
this is the presidential election French
presidential election we can see that we
can almost assume presidential election
has a date right and based on the March
and February like local maximum you can
almost make a model to predict that the
day to get a lot of coverage because the
closer we get the more clicking is there
so so it turns out that there is a
estimation guestimation that we can
actually make about it yeah me know so
wrapping it up okay so now we are
creating pipeline in hosted on Microsoft
Azure which allows to do all this
analysis in real time and in other
output it will present some report in
power bi so we have daily scheduled web
job with downloads data from Facebook
and sent e1 and also done those articles
and from from from web and uses our
algorithm
content extraction to yes it's all in
Python web shop is just Python script
run everyday on other outputs of this
step are stored in data like store which
is something like HDFS but on Asia and
then each week each week we have another
web job which is another part
script run every week which takes data
from this data leg store takes saved
model from from blob storage updates the
model makes new predictions using that
model on the data from the italic store
save this to SQL Server database and to
that database is the database is
connected to power power bi which
generates reports for our marketing team
super easy but how much curse words went
through to make it actually yes oh so
it's actually we done but if you're
doing it for the first time on Azure
it's a lot of a lot of pain mostly about
connecting things but then it is very
stable it works like without any issues
for like now a few months and so yeah
and it's super cheap like one run costs
like less than a dollar so it's it's
super cheap doesn't really matter so
yeah after we deployed the power bi it's
actually operational like guys login
every week underst content planning
session and see what phrases are hot
what phrases should we begin our
headline Swift or what what topics we
should write maybe within a week month
or something like that and the content
plan is actually affected by what we did
and yeah we also had a choice I mean a
chance to make a presentation for you I
hope it wasn't too boring so any
questions guys yes
yeah we measured the improvement on the
headlines if they change it and it's
statistically over 30 to 40 percent
increase on an average basis to the
reference not including our regular user
growth so the the clicks based on the on
the whenever the article was shown yes
we have implemented a be testing in all
our article titles and that's how we can
measure the effect
yeah because Lda output is a vector of
whatever amount I mean less you want but
we tested with Martic marketing people
how many words they need in order to
actually describe I mean I understand
what the topic is about and it turns out
is between ten to fifteen
depends on how because on no no so yeah
but this is the hyper parameters of Lda
so you can tell them to find how many
topics you want and how general or how
deep should they be and we wanted pretty
specific topics in this case so
therefore you don't need a lot of words
to describe a topic about it actually
and because it's no stop words usually
the word make a meaning to you instantly
from the from reading but the other
question I think you want to ask is like
what's the cutoff point for it for a
article to know what the article is
about and we decided that we use 20% but
this is pure expert judgment and we
wanted no more than three topics for
article but this this is this is
something that you can tune maybe you
want five tags maybe you want just
dominant article with at least 40%
chance that is that these articles about
this is purely based on your use case
you can tune it 100 but we will tune it
along the way I think we think because
we observe how often the topics come up
and disappear so based on the number of
articles who intake in this case it's
60,000 it's for one year and with our
current host pace so so you you want to
know how much how much of topics you
cover and you can optimize that based on
what's the minimal virality you actually
care about and because we don't care
about boring [ __ ] we can we can limit
ourselves to the number of topics turns
out hundred topics is is the amount you
actually right now want to read
finance and social issues because people
don't need more it's good enough thank
you very much
you